okay so yesterday donald trump had
another one of these coronavirus press
briefings
this one was particularly bad even by
the standards that we've come to
apply to these press briefings and there
was something
trump seemed to sort of just lack energy
he seemed deflated
it was almost like he had the wind taken
out of him
just before coming out to brief the
press he seemed maybe out of gas
is the right analogy he was disoriented
he was confused during the brief
presentation part
when it was time for questions he called
on mostly friendly reporters
some of whom asked ridiculous questions
and then just slowly walked off
after not taking too many questions now
the content is of course really
disturbing
we now have the additional contrast of
biden harris right and we really start
to get the sense
as we think about that and we see the
continued deterioration
that almost anyone almost anyone would
have better dealt with coronavirus than
this administration
these are just not people up to the task
uh and i want to go through some of
these moments with you
now it's it's almost becoming more sad
and depressing than anything else
in addition to being horrifying that
this is the guy
who's in charge of the country right now
let's start with coronavirus from
yesterday again
an administration just out of ideas no
ideas about what to do
they have come up with what is this
genius talking point
of talking about the percentage
increases
in other countries take a look at this
but the virus continues to
increase in nations across the globe
last week france and germany both
recorded their highest daily number
of new cases in three months
not that i want to bring that up but
might as well
explain it to the media the seven day
case average for germany has
increased by 62 percent since last week
unfortunately
and that is truly unfortunate it's
increased 82 percent in france 113
percent in spain and 30 percent in the
united kingdom
those are big increases cases are also
rapidly increasing in the netherlands
sweden belgium
slovakia estonia and other european
countries
and in our country they're going down
now it's important to note that
the reason trump now talks about
the percentage increases in a lot of
countries
is because the numbers in those
countries are still
tiny compared to our numbers even on a
per capita basis
so trump has to say because otherwise
these would be really dumb things to say
i mean they're dumb anyway but nobody
would fall for them
trump has to say percentage-wise here's
what we're seeing in other countries now
this is important in two ways
number one the reactions
in these other countries are completely
different to in the united states in the
united states we've been
sort of hovering between when we got
down to 20 000 new cases a day
half the country pretended like it was
over we reopened and we got up to nearly
80 000 cases a day we've now come back
from those numbers
so when you never really go down when
you just have a raging pandemic in the
united states for what is now many many
months
percentage-wise you're not going to see
drastic changes because it's just
it's been bad and it remains bad in
these european countries and other
countries they
so successfully dealt with the virus
that
once you get down really low even small
increases in terms of the number of
cases are
high increases in terms of percentage
that's one thing to understand about
the the sort of just arithmetic of it
the other piece
is in these other countries as soon as
they started to see these upticks
they immediately say we've got to start
shutting things down
we've got to expand guidelines we have
to tighten and expand
mask wearing etc so when trump points to
this
the numbers are deceptive
because of how poorly we dealt with it
when it never got good
it's just going to kind of stay bad and
and even on a percentage basis
but we just continue plodding along like
idiots
collectively obviously many of us
individually are doing the right things
while these other countries immediately
react now the
the other thing i think it's important
to mention is just how small the numbers
are in some of these places you know
trump mentions germany
germany had 436 cases on monday
we had 40 000 and even on a per capita
adjusted basis
we have so many more cases than the
countries that donald trump is the
these are outbreaks that you can't even
really compare
because they are qualitatively and
quantitatively
so different uh then trump has become
focused and fixated really almost
obsessed on college football
he wants college football to start now
it's very clear trump knows very little
about sports and doesn't really care
about sports and in fact videos we've
seen of trump watching sports he looks
very very bored and
doesn't really seem to get sports but
here he is acting like
college football is a really really big
thing that he wants to see happen right
away
as we safely restore our great economy
and reopen our schools and hopefully
we can watch colleges play football we
want to get football in colleges
these are young strong people they won't
have a big problem
with the china virus
so we want to see college football start
and hopefully a lot of
great people are going to be out there
they're going to be out there playing
football
and they'll be able to fight it off and
hopefully it won't bother them one bit
most of them will never get it
statistically but we know we'll see more
cases at some point and
we will eventually develop sufficient
immunity
in addition to everything else that
we're doing so college football get out
there and play football people want to
see it and stand for your american flag
stand for your national anthem because
people are not happy when
that doesn't happen something about the
billionaire president
telling unpaid college athletes to just
go out there and play
and that most of them will be fine that
seems
a little bit dystopian to me and by the
way
is is it bad that i've been so
desensitized to trump calling it the
china virus that
i don't even find the need to comment on
that like is that a bad thing that's
going on
uh like it's it's become so pedestrian
almost for him to refer to it that way
that it's barely even worth a mention
and in reality what else is there to say
about it
on the facts by the way multiple college
football players have already started to
develop
heart conditions as a result of catching
coronavirus
and so as usual donald trump is also
wrong on the facts
then of course donald trump
mispronounces
kamala harris's name as
kamala is concerned she's a now my
fellow
uh battle star galactica fans will
remember that one kamala i believe
was like a drug that people took in
battle star galactica it's been a little
while since i watched it but fact check
me
on that one i think you will find that i
am i am right more substantively
sort of immediately as expected donald
trump starts attacking kamala harris and
says that she's nasty she's a woman and
she's nasty take a look she had a lot of
things happening and
so i was a little surprised that he
picked her i've been watching her for a
long time and
i was a little surprised she was
extraordinarily nasty to
kavanage judge kavanaugh then now
justice cavanaugh she was nasty to a
level that was
just a horrible thing the way she was
the way she treated
now justice kavanaugh and i won't forget
that soon
so she did very poorly in the primaries
and now she's chosen so let's see how
that all works
the nasty to kavanaugh thing i find
fascinating because she actually had the
strength to question
brett kavanaugh the way he deserved to
be questioned
and you know these these guys like trump
they claim to be super alpha
and powerful and strong and yet
they can't stand up to questioning trump
regularly can't stand up to questioning
from female reporters and that seems to
trigger him way more
than questioning from male reporters
kamala harris
asking good questions of brett kavanaugh
makes her
nasty in trump's mind and this is
definitely a preview of what we can
expect in the campaign
from here on out they're so mean they're
so nasty they're being so horrible to us
well
you just don't like it when your
narrative is questioned when your echo
chamber is pierced that's all it is
then trump again just struggling to
speak uh here he keeps repeating
anarchists for some reason and he keeps
repeating it until he gets it wrong
take a listen you really are anarchists
he's a left-wing anarchist
they are anarchists and i'm directing
the department
very strange very strange he also talked
about
plasma rather than plasma although i
won't that that's like every day i'm not
even going to play that for you
and then lastly again sort of a very
down
sad trump throwing out some last
smears of kamala harris before
hanging his head and just wandering away
from the podium after taking only a few
questions
or modify it to a point where it's
essentially no longer the second
amendment
i would have thought he would have gone
a different way thank you very much
so what do you think is does trump gain
anything by doing these press briefings
uh kellyanne
these press briefings you'll remember
stopped they started slowing down
and then they stopped all together after
the disaster where trump wondered aloud
about maybe injecting bleach
or isopropyl alcohol um in order to
treat coronavirus
kellyanne conway then suggested publicly
the reason trump's approval is down is
he stopped the briefings
and he shortly thereafter restarted them
and you know
what is true is that the polls have been
tightening since he restarted them
causation and correlation are two
different things
and i think we can probably point to
other explanations if we want to look
for them but
is this helping trump to some degree or
is he doing more damage does it not
matter
we hear about ratings but at the same
time most of the country is not watching
these
let me know what you think we will have
continued coverage
of the fiasco just ghastly press
briefings
on the david pakman show instagram
that's david pakman show
and we also of course every day have the
full hour audio podcast available around
3 p.m eastern if you prefer a long form
audio version of the show you don't have
to watch clips on youtube i
love it when you do but if you prefer
the sort of long-form audio format that
you can take with you easily
you can subscribe to the daily audio
podcast on
spotify itunes google play really
whatever your favorite podcasting app is
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience 25
off your first order this has been a
game changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water to rehydrate your body
because it is packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way of getting
yourself rehydrated
and it tastes awesome there's a variety
of flavors
i have blood orange which i love you can
also get grapefruit
and lime a lot of us don't even realize
when we're dehydrated a lot of the time
and it's become a really uh great part
of my daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think you
never fully understand this until you
use hydrant for the first time
i get a great uh a boost of energy when
i'm properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated
they also have a version with caffeine
which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets 25 off your
first order
when you go to drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video